zelda is an anniversary it came out a
long time ago 30 years ago and I can't
see far far away yeah but yeah man yeah
turns 30 I guess this week's Sunday I'm
simultaneously making a lot of people
feel very old and also stirring
nostalgia in there and they're in their
bosom as a work and I didn't grow up
playing zelda games my first one was
actually I guess gamecube was so-so
phantom tendon I was about taking the
time to find a vein well that's wind
waker sorry wind waker was the first
person delta game i ever played which is
the one that holds up the best like when
you look at it like graphically look
really good yeah they made this cell
shaded graphic at the time like we all
derided it as being this kind of crappy
looking kiddie game like is it this
isn't zelda that i know but now when you
look back at it you're like this still
looks amazing like that cell shading was
such a great idea for making a long
lasting it was crazy cuz the trailer
they showed for like what the gamecube
could do with Zelda was the more
realistic like twilight princess art
style then they came out of left field
but yeah it's it's great it's so
different and it stands out at 30 years
so we're obviously going to make a big
deal about it on gang spots as a bunch
of really cool features going up later
on this week we grow obviously gonna do
it oh yeah I mean pokemons a week after
that yeah it's just that's what's gonna
be now it's gonna be bursaries after
anniversary but like not many games have
this thing staying power like 30 years
like it's such a long long time we think
about those already nez games you think
about like we were saying before and
about all the crappy ones like the the
Phillips was a CDI games that released
like they had some it was a misstep but
that was a misstep that was giving it to
another developer right and it's not
that they didn't ever do that again
because you had like Oracle of see the
Oracle of Ages minish cap seasons and
those were done by completely different
development studios Capcom but it made
them really distrust American developers
for a while I think so do you think
that's what is the staying power of a
franchise like this like 4 30 years to
keep that quality bars it's just as
Nintendo or super protective of their
other games and they just do right by
them I think they were able to identify
what people liked about the original and
I think they learned a lot about that
from the second game because it was so
different and I think those two games
combined in
formed somewhat of a formula for the
series that Nintendo has pretty much
stuck to for the most part and even if
they deviate and do something a little
bit different with some of the more
experimental games like four swords and
the like they still always come back to
the one that everyone knew and loved and
in doing so they you know they're giving
people what they want really and then
they innovate once in a while until
things everyone yeah they do that great
job of having a core experience like no
matter what when you get into it you
know there's gonna be a link there's
gonna be zelda there's almost always
gonna be Gannon but they're able to
experiment in ways that Nintendo does so
well they do the same thing with Mario
that each of those games feels fresh and
new and exciting ways while while still
keeping that core here's the theme and
you get the music and you're like oh
this is a Zelda game I was so excited to
be in this character again it's kind of
this weird thing where Mario is like the
quintessential 2d platformer experience
and then when everyone else tries to
make a 2d platformer they can't just
make Mario they have to like do
something fresh with it where's Mariana
just has this like nice column of this
like traditional gameplay that people
know and Zelda's almost kind of a
similar thing where it's it's it's like
every video game you start off as this
low power character and then you collect
things and you go adventuring places you
find new areas and you get more better
abilities and they've almost like
cornered the market on this sort of this
thing that just works so good for video
games so then they can I guess it erase
in different ways without losing too
much of that core gameplay again it's
also how they tinker with Hyrule itself
because I rule is always somewhat
familiar like yeah it's a kingdom sort
of like a medieval kind of a feel to it
like in a way it's all very fantasy but
it also changes quite a bit over time as
well and even the sort of like the laws
of you know physics that define that
world also changed it yeah it's like
they're just really good it's sort of
taking that thing that everyone knows
like you were saying the core and just
twisting it a little bit of us
interested and they do something that I
think final fantasies like square tries
to do with final fantasy where you have
a core idea like this is magic and these
are people who are going to explore a
world but I feel like they over the
years they've changed so much that it's
almost unrecognizable to someone who
played the original final fantasy yes
where zelda is very recognized same
characters you're in not only the same
character in the sames world it's like
now I'm just in this world that's put
into 3d and that's something that's very
thick fur for me like having grown up
with it like I get into this world night
under
and it immediately whereas in someone
who's getting into a for the first time
like they understand this in a whole new
way but in a way that relates to them is
like here the game experiences that I've
already had and there are a lot of fries
yeah just like Madden and bunch of great
comments coming through here on the twit
shot on a games watch out and munch
chomp says it just had so many standout
moments in ocarina of time no other game
in the franchise really had that story
hit after it for you guys what were your
favorite zelda games ocarina time
obviously the first 10 out of 10 on
gamespot back in there was nineteen
ninety-eight like it's a lot of people's
favorites yeah for me it's always been
majora's mask like Majora's Mask took
the ideas of Zelda and put it into an
adventure game rapper like I love
adventure games having grown up with
like old pc adventure games Sierra Lucas
Sierra okay but we're done it took those
it's those ideas and like made it into a
3d world where the purpose was still
like you're still getting stronger you
still collecting items and weapons and
you have the great combat and music of
Zelda but it's more about interacting
with people and exploring and talking
and trying to figure out this world it's
like a perfect adventure game and I
think the 3ds version just made that
even better like being able to explore
things and figure out what you need to
do and where you need to go like it was
such an improvement on that hmm so for
me via Madura link to the past which is
is difficult because I really loved the
original Zelda so much that was the one
I grew up with and as a young kid I
didn't really know how to do how to like
complete the game but I enjoyed an
adventure but i'll link to the past is
when i was kind of like competent enough
to like take a video game understand it
see if to through to the end and i still
find the art style really charming i
still find the the two different worlds
like the light in the dark world very
interesting because it's the same place
but different and i think they did that
at a time when it wasn't really i've
seen the Drover's do ya know what
anything like I remember you you were
getting through that and you think you
you beat the game like really early on
like oh I'm here I'm gonna beat the bad
guy and I saved the princess like holy
[ __ ] there's a whole other world and you
want a crazy trip and you're in like the
apocalypse I didn't no wonder you like
me like yourself I yeah and you know
even again I think that game established
for the series like when you explore and
you run into something that you realize
like I don't know what to do here but I
know that I will find a solution that
will make me want to come back
you talk of it sorry you look a bit like
only to the pan of pasta yeah like you
know just you encounter like a wall you
can't break or like a waterfall like you
can see that you can go through your
like aunt go through that waterfall like
what what is the thing I'm missing an
initially you find the tool and you can
do it again it's a lot like the metra
metroid formula and i think those two
games share a lot in common but because
of their perspective people don't
usually come yeah but they're very
similar it's interesting some folks in
the chopper saying as well and saying
how recours game that seems to be sort
of taking some ideas from those as well
and applying them and I link between
worlds then I guess sort of an echo of a
Link to the Past 2013 game of the year
for gamespot com as well it said such a
good job of distilling all those
elements that work for the traditional
kinds of Zelda like include the first
one Ocarina of Time not octreotide a
link to the past but making it feel very
fresh and modern and I really love the
way that it approached dungeons that up
to this time we'd always thought if the
dungeon is like here's the place where I
go and I get the item and then I can
find the next dungeon this one was
basically you have all the items you
have all the tools that you need right
in front of you explore and do whatever
you want with those I mean there was
such a fun way to expect to change up
that formula briefly let's talk about
some of the the stinkers what was the
game may be like okay number one
explicitly bad games i'm guessing those
CDI yeah hand what hand of fate certain
wand of gamilon game alanya those were
just was those aren't even sold it was
not the was it the cartoon was a thought
that was that would excuse me princess
that's from one of those games it was
from the cartoon art style is similarly
is even worse like it million cartoon
look good which is mind-boggling I don't
even know who could have green let this
like no one at Nintendo was like this is
a good idea yeah but someone had to have
made this intron all of this and gone
like this make another game this is so
much fun and cool the voice acting is
awful that's atrocious that I was like
lost in translation or something where
they just didn't have the good people
nintendo of america or something keeping
an eye over is and yeah but then they
did a lot of drugs look at there had to
be mushrooms something use me drug
dinner and and then I guess games that
sort of maybe didn't reach the high
water mark set by the game when I was
younger I did not like Zelda to know
here it is look actually yeah this is
yeah oh it's just so cat that Jesus a
slice it's embarrassed like this the
kind of the dogs Freddy Krueger if you
made it you're like I'm not gonna put
that my resume it is for is it his bomb
god-awful yeah I couldn't wrap my head
around sold the 2i there it was so I
mean the first game was kind of obtuse
anyway but this one was just like it was
such a departure that anything that I
thought I'd learn from the original game
was just thrown out the window like on
the overworld map the first time I
remember running into an enemy and then
it transported me to this like 2d
perspective it was just like how does
that make sense like before I was
engaging in the moment with that enemy
now I'm putting to a level that has
multiple enemies mm-hmm just because I
ran into one on the map they're so
strange it was more for me it was
because of the challenge like I was not
used to that kind of game playing it was
a very challenging game it was very
punishing that if you screw up you're
going back to the beginning like wow
that was it was almost a roguelike in
that sense where you have to know what
you're doing and get through it in the
number of lives that you had for me like
I don't think I could have beat the
ending when I was a child without a
Nintendo Power I don't know how you
would have fought like you have to turn
into a fairy and then fall through this
very specific bridge to go through a
keyhole and you have a specific
lightning spell that you need to use
against the final enemy or else it's not
going to do anything because that spell
never does anything else and any other
point in the game like really beautiful
and it especially in an age before the
Internet at 30 years long time last one
on this Luna nine in the twitch chat
saying I was so lucky dorina was the
first game ever played back when I was
four or five to which prepared death
says Wow four or five makes me feel old
30 years but you're 30 more years as
Elvis
you